[Music]
angels
even if you haven't touched the bible
you probably have an idea on what they
look like
they're those elegant heavenly beings
with long white robes
swan like wings and perhaps a halo on
top for good measure we also know what
angel babies or cherubs look like
those small chubby cute infants clasping
a bow and arrow
the kind of thing you might see on a
valentine's day card except well
that's not what angels actually look
like not according to the bible
these are biblically accurate angels
these horrifying abominations are more
suited to an h.b lovecraft novel
not really the bible so what are these
things why do they look this way
and how have we got angels so wrong
okay so angels come from the old
testament the first half of the bible
for christians
or the whole bible known as the tanakh
for jews the old testament was written
down in modern-day israel and palestine
from about the 6th century bce to the
3rd century bce
although many scholars believe the
biblical stories themselves are much
older
we get the word angel from the greek
angelos originally from the hebrew word
malach
which roughly translates to messenger
these messengers
appear in the old testament a number of
times they carry god's messages from
heaven and earth
and sometimes act on his behalf for
example you might recognize the angel of
death in the passover story
that slaughtered all the first sons of
the egyptians
or perhaps the angel that struck 70 000
israelites to death
and the angel that single-handedly
killed 185
000 assyrian soldiers in one night when
they appear in the bible they are
described as having wings
in fact they look like any ordinary
person
in the later biblical texts such as
daniel some even get names
gabriel raphael and michael okay
this all sounds familiar but they're not
quite the nightmare material
freak abominations we saw before the
angels
known as malach are not the only
heavenly beings in the bible
there's a hierarchy of them and
depending on who you ask your classic
humanoid angels
are actually pretty far down the ladder
in the middle ages
a jewish scholar known as my modernities
drew up a hierarchy of angels and if you
look here
your classic humanoid angels the malach
are pretty low down
but not quite as low as cherubim forget
those chubby winged angels
according to the bible cherubim are
animal human hybrids
the first time we see them is in the
book of genesis right after adam and eve
have been kicked out the garden
their job is to guard the garden of eden
from mankind
our best description of cherubim comes
to the book of ezekiel
it opens with a prophet experiencing a
profound vision in his vision
ezekiel describes them as living
creatures but they are later revealed in
chapter 10
as cherubim his account is as follows
in the middle of it was something like
four living creatures
this was their appearance they were of
human form
each had four faces and each of them had
four wings
their legs were straight and their soles
of their feet were like the sole of a
calf's foot
and they sparkled like burnished bronze
under their wings on their four sides
they had human hands
and the four had their faces and their
wings thus
their wings touched one another each of
them moved straight ahead without
turning as they moved
as for the appearance of their faces the
four had the face of a human being
the face of a lion on their right side
the face of an ox on their left side
and the face of an eagle such were their
faces
their wings were spread out above each
creature had two wings
each of which touched the wing of
another while two covered their bodies
each moved straight ahead wherever the
spirit would go
they went without turning as they went
in the middle of the living creatures
there was something that looked like
burning coals of fire
like torches moving to and fro among the
living creatures
the fire was bright and lightning issued
from the fire
the living creatures darted to and fro
like a flash of lightning
the cherubim don't look like your
average angel instead
they look more like the mythical beasts
in ancient mesopotamia
especially the babylonian iamasu which
is the wings of an eagle
the body of a lion and the head of a
king these would act as guardians to
sacred places like temples
or the palace or city walls and
performed a similar role to the biblical
cherubim
they look similar to their egyptian
cousin the sphinx or the hittite griffin
many believed that these biblical angels
were descendants of these mythological
creatures from mesopotamia
there would have been a lot of cultural
exchange and the same sorts of mythical
creatures would crop
up across these regions
cherubim and later christianity may have
been imported from greek and roman myths
borrowing from the shapes of cupid or
pluto
moving up the list we get these guys
seraphim
they have six wings two used for flying
and the other pair for covering the
angel's face
and the third pair for covering the
angel's feet they're described in the
book of isaiah
as follows seraphs were in attendance
above him
each had six wings with two they covered
their faces
and with two they covered their feet and
with two they flew
and one called the other and said holy
holy holy is the lord of hosts
and the whole earth is full of his glory
in medieval christian theology
seraphim is the highest choir of the
angelic hierarchy
they are the caretakers of god's throne
again continuously singing
holy holy holy all day
every day so seraphim their name comes
from the word seraph
to burn so seraphim may mean something
like the burning ones
okay where do they come from going
further into seraphine's name
reveals its origins the hebrew word for
a venomous serpent of the desert
is saraf in ancient egypt the cobra was
often referred to as the flaming one
an image of which called urayus was worn
by the pharaoh
thus saraf may be the hebrew term for
cobra
and perhaps where our seraphim get their
winged appearance from
now we're getting to the strangest
beings in the bible the ophanim
or simply known as the wheels they're a
pair of interlocking gold wheels
with eyes around the outside and they
hover and float in the sky
in the same vision as before ezekiel
describes them alongside the cherubim
quote as i look to the living creatures
i saw a wheel on the earth beside the
living creatures
one for each of the four of them as for
the appearance of the wheels and the
construction
their appearance was like the gleaming
of beryl and the four had the same form
their construction being something like
a wheel within a wheel
when they moved they moved in any of the
four directions without veering as they
moved
their rims were tall and awesome for the
rims of all four
were full of eyes all around when the
living creatures moved
the wheels moved beside them and when
the living creatures rose from the earth
the wheels rose wherever the spirit
would go
they went and the wheels rose along with
them
for the spirit of the living creatures
was in the wheels
the wheels are beings who are meant to
carry god's throne making them some of
the holiest
and certainly the strangest beings in
the bible where do these wheels come
from
well no one really knows this one
conspiracy theorists believe that
ezekiel is describing ufo
due to its strange shape and movement or
perhaps
seeing that this all takes place in a
trippy vision it could be the product of
the prophet ingesting a psychedelic
plant
more grounded scholars interpret the
wheels metaphorically a stand-in for
god's unknowability
or some other often quite elaborate
interpretation
but ultimately no one really knows much
more about the wheels
they're never mentioned anywhere else
there is some confusion about whether
these eldritch abominations known as
cherubim
seraphim or ophanim are really actually
angels
perhaps heavenly being is a better
description of them
whatever it may be the bible's view of
heaven is not the exclusive domain of
these beautiful winged humanoids
if heaven is in fact real you'll likely
be spending a literal eternity alongside
these winged monstrosities instead
hey thanks to the end of this video i
enjoyed this one about angels and their
creepy origins
if you want more like comment but most
will subscribe to this channel